a bunch of responses my drone help video
not to mention responses from flight
tests and cells which are the guys that
make the body of the drone that I got
that's really cool so thank you
everybody for all the help this weekend
I may be sitting down cracking open a
beer and going to town on that thing and
making it for the high rents a big fan
of you guys in flight test there some
Kasich guess I'm watching this video I
don't know who exactly is doing it but
basically completely useless
we can't edit anything right now with
any of the stuff they gave us
so first oh no no no man the knife dude
it's not me I swear
and I am oh snap alien boy yeah this is
definitely heavier maybe that means it's
better we've actually had these little
things for almost a year now way before
all the Viners and stars had them we've
we're pretty much full hipster yeah so
this thing has seen better days the
gears don't really work it spins well
going this way barely spins it all going
this way grinds makes a lot of noises
check out how clutch this thing is like
oh you want to go this way stop the our
3ds were never meant for editing we
already have like six mandates on it
already so we have mac drives with mac
pro with our 3ds and they're like fake
reeling and there's problems so we can
target their license so that sucks and I
have a plasma grenade stuck to my head
double sucks
I want to try to see just how fast I can
spin on this thing
oh I got to be